is it wrong
for what age do I want to do a 32 year
old man to date an 18 year old no nope
no I judge him for it okay if anyone's
raise your hand if you think yes
all right I'm gonna raise my hand no I
need a yes or no yes or no come on
everyone grows up at different ages okay
it depends okay
what depends what she's listening she
looks I don't know an 18 some of them
look like they're 18 when they're 13.
because you're like how did you say it
was he's 32 she's 18.
all right at 32.
when you sit down with an 18 year old
what are you talking about like what is
she like no for real like generally what
is she offering you like and I mean if
she's okay I mean
you're just a baby I feel yeah you're
just talking about one dimension and I
look at you and I'm like all right you
as a man let's say you have stuff in
common let's say like maybe maybe you're
into the same stuff maybe they're both
Gamers I don't know okay and that's
that's what off the top of my head I'm
like it's not in of itself wrong but I
do raise an eyebrow because I do Wonder
like like you question the guy a little
bit I questioned the guy a little bit
like what do you like because all right
I'm he's seriously dating or is he just
having fun like in your scenario uh
let's say let's say seriously dating
okay so you've looked at this he's like
he's looking for a wife all right cool
and so I'm here and I'm like so in this
18 year old who is like a few years off
from being a child you're like in you I
see a partner and someone I want to
build and someone I want to model my
potential daughters after all of that
really and I'm like bro like off an 18
year old it kind of depends though if if
she's like someone that's been like
working out doing their flat living by
herself independent then you kind of
because a lot of women mature a lot
quicker as well
you could have an 18 year old that
literally acts like a 25 year old you
don't even know anything yeah no it
depends in it like some 18 year olds are
in uni yeah and they're basically kids
yeah that's what I'm thinking it's like
you're right it kind of depends on I
mean it and that's why I struggled to
put my hand up
yeah yeah but it's like it's because
sometimes you're like oh she's 18 and
she's in uni and she's only lived with
her parents and she's coming out and
you're visiting her dorm in Union
she wants a family maybe she's 18.
that's still the same Dimension we're
talking about looks and fertility that's
it that's what you pick your partner
right I got something in common okay
yeah
I just struggled to with the idea that
an 18 year old girl in uni is
stimulating your mind and spirit like
and if she is I kind of I just think
like when I was 18 versus 21 like oh
isn't that different like I'm just I'm
just thinking like mentally I don't
think I was that different at 18 from
21. I don't think there is that much
difference yeah and no one would really
bat an eye at 21. no I I moved out when
I was 18 and I was working so I was I
was you know pretty much a full grown
adult at 18. all right denelva tell me
why why is it now and then when you go
next why why is the problem yeah and all
the man I think it's really down to the
different stages of emotional maturity
and growth when you're 18 although yes
you can be mature and this never even
not experienced the how many extra 14
years extra of life that he has
experienced he has that over you and I
think that it's not about manipulation
it's just about the point the fact that
there'll be a certain moment in both of
their lives where you're just going to
realize we're not on the same level
we're not in the same frequency and
that's really important that's what do
you mean in the same because a lot of
times we use these words I don't even
know what they mean this in the same
frequency yeah the same frequency
meaning like okay when you're now 40 I'm
just about to turn 30. in like five
every five years I I feel like every
five years I go through quite a lot of
change you know you especially then with
decades you look back on your life and
you think about so many things you
reflect and your mind may change that's
why you can see the difference between a
20 year old woman and a 30 year old
woman so I just think is a bit dangerous
when you're kind of dealing with
somebody that's so far away from where
you're at at your age so for example for
me that's why I say I'll date somebody
that is younger than me by two years Max
and Max five years older because I don't
want it to be too far away do you feel
like limits your pool a little bit
um I I think that at this point I'm more
just looking for the right person and
from what I know about myself I feel
like what I need is that limit
okay um what do you think
um yeah I think an 18 year old obviously
there's different kinds of 18 year olds
but they've got a lot of
experiences to go through I think 32 is
a bit old I think like 28 29 is fine but
why would a
and maybe you guys can answer that you
men why would a 32 year old want an 18
year old is it just because she's more
likely to be a virgin and
is that the main reason why you would go
for one because I wouldn't like
be like uh but I'd be a bit confused
like why wouldn't you go for someone
who's maybe like mid-20s or like even 21
like what's the reason I don't know yeah
I think I think it's wild to be honest I
wouldn't like legit so I can't can I can
I just make a side note on this
um not that I agree with the Fate 2 and
and the 18 year old but
I I feel like it comes down to the
individual yeah I've come across 40 year
olds 50 year olds that'll in many cases
less mature than 18 year olds
so and I think it goes both way
irrespective of your gender
um but what was your question just in
terms what would be the reason for that
would it just be because she's likely to
have less bodies as that the main reason
um
cool
um because like initially what I do
think of it 30 to 18 yeah that is a
pretty big like Gap and I would like
look at it a type of way
but I feel like
if we come to a common agreement on what
a guy is usually looking for or what a
girl is usually looking for they kind of
meet each other where they need you know
I mean because
I hope you guys can agree well but um
you know men very I value beauty and I
value youth fertility so if I'm at the
age of 32
sure I could go for someone 25 26 but I
think like nowadays most of those women
already they're very like
career driven they're very they have
like this past bit mentality so I feel
like they're gonna be way more combative
than the 18 year old because I feel like
if she comes into this
um space
she's gonna value
that I reach this point and then she's
gonna be more agree agreeable with me
because then I I can also like teach her
I want okay I want to say teacher but
you can guide it is someone that's older
is more set in their ways exactly yeah
100 so I just feel like this 18 year old
maybe she has she's as matures I mean I
would say it's the same thing like if
you date an older guy and you try to
change him you're mad like why would you
if you if I dated a 50 year old am I
expecting him to change after 50 years
of living his life one way exactly
that's all they know so it's like the
younger you go because
obviously most of the time 18 year old
is gonna look
um better than 26 28 year old so it's
like if I value that then and I see that
they can agree to me what I want to do
long term it's like why why not choose
that instead of okay so I have a
question so we're talking about changing
people so in this scenario in in the
scenarios I usually posed we're talking
about the fact that there's a need to
change a woman because obviously he's
older he's going to be set in his way so
the man is cool we always just have to
assume that Amanda is 30 is mature in
doing his thing all the time and he can
take care of a 18 year old woman and
murder to be what he wants when in fat
people he doesn't even know what he
wants exactly so I think it's really
quite dangerous to play that game and if
it were to twist to turn the the the
story and make it I don't think it's
good to influence the person you're with
like you don't want a guy that you can
follow
yeah but I also want a guy that can also
follow me too because I'm not just going
to be adapting to someone on my own so
you want to follow and then he follows
yeah I want us to grow together yeah I
want it to be like this but I think it's
a dangerous game playing with the idea
we want to change people like you're
dating someone because you like them
you're not dating them because you see
potential and you want to manipulate I
think relationships compromise yeah yeah
so I just think like that I just think
if you're the person
um I looked up political ideologies this
is seems off topic but I have a point
um when I was younger because I was
curious like what makes people change
their minds and like what things
influence them and the number one thing
that influences your political ideology
over time is your partner like you kind
of rub off on the person you're with
yeah I agree the longer you're with
someone the more you become like them
and you agree because you want to be
familiar you want to be the same to them
but it's not necessarily a good thing
but yeah foreign
don't you think that people should like
as they're like so young they're 18 like
don't you think they should find their
own way in life like yeah like thinking
a 32 year old might be helpful for them
and like working out these life like
problems and stuff and like fight like
they can guide them in their way but
like I think trying to change someone
that's so young it's just like backwards
like they need to find their own way in
life they need to find who they are and
I don't think it should depend on
somebody else to find that way in life
like I don't think they should like like
I don't know it's just like they're so
young and impressionable like a year ago
they were 17 like and you wouldn't date
a 17 year old so I don't know I just
think back to when I was 18 and I don't
think I was that crazy different than
the way I am now
yeah I don't know I just think like in
general I mean 18 is a bit young for
like I I don't know if I would push like
18 year olds to get married but
um
I don't know I just think like as women
you kind of avoid a lot of like
heartbreak and Trauma if you get married
earlier like I have a friend that got
married at like 21 22 and she's probably
the happiest like person how does she
know uh 27 28. Oh that's not yeah or
don't or don't get married
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible